[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dan lebatard hosted the dan levitard
show with stu godz co-founder of
meadowlark media joining us on the
program good morning dan how are you is
it is it dan you only call me when this
unending river of diarrhea that is the
miami dolphins does something
nationally to embarrass our region and
stain everything that used to be
dolphins football is it really you call
to laugh at me hmm not no with you
no
no i am trying to ascertain with the
strongest parts of my soul whether or
not you have any use for this
relationship except when an offensive
line coach does cocaine or an offensive
lineman bully somebody else like the
only times you call me
i i saw you yesterday i was insane with
jealousy you're talking to pat mcafee
about the origins of his career but me
no it's only when the dolphins do
something stupid
it's infuriating it's hurtful i was
excited like we played yesterday we had
a 65-yard pass in training camp that
represented the best thing that's
happened here in 20 years and we got so
excited that we were playing t-pain's
terrible dolphin song yesterday listen
to this
wow
in my heart and then
and then i'm like and then i'm avoiding
when i see your call come on i'm like
really they're calling me again it's the
only time they're interested in me
oh that song can really inspire you to
maybe tamper or tank
which one do you want to talk about dan
with your dolphins
the incompetence is laughably
amusing at this point is it not that you
would
this is the greatest winner we've known
and
they lose the draft picks that it would
have cost to actually get him so they
only
fail to get him
and in so doing the media gets
everything wrong on the front end of
this dan if you remember how some of
this broke adam schefter and darlington
were out there for a weekend with the
report that brady was retiring when he
publicly sent out the statement that
wasn't meant as a retirement it was
meant as goodbye to tampa and boston
gets mad because they're like why
weren't we mentioned well you weren't
mentioned because it wasn't meant as a
retirement like he was coming to be the
quarterback for the dolphins or to try
to be through the executive route you
know trying to do lebron stuff because
he's figured out with the player
empowerment that he's worth 375 million
dollars as a side job that nobody knows
he's any good at because he can do
anything he wants and this was such a
gangster move that was almost executed
and the dolphins just screwed all of it
up and it didn't happen only because of
the unprecedented lawsuit that involves
racism that cost them their coach okay
but can you at least respect the
dolphins that they're they're trying to
win
so they're they tampered they tried to
get sean payton tried to get brady they
tried to tank so they could get joe
burrow
so they're at least they're at least
trying
i love that take and we mocked chris
cody for that take yesterday because how
irresponsible it is you're out here
actively advocating
for do everything you can to win
including cheating uh just do it well
and don't get caught yes
i can't believe that that's where your
career
[Laughter]
is that he failed yes
they failed to successfully cheat well
as opposed to cheating poorly yeah
i'm with you would you rather have joe
burrow or tom brady
um i
wow well come on i'd rather have joe
burrow because well no you're right i'd
rather not brady because he's going to
last longer than bro
he's going to play into he's going to be
playing now that's a hot take right
there that's a hug
it's just the most obvious thing brady
is still going to bring a winning super
bowl actively dragging a dialysis
machine with the nurses from hospice
running after him how confident are you
in tua
this year
i believe in the dolphins this year for
the first time in
twenty
well but they've they're masking it you
say no no no tua but garoppolo got
within a throw of being a champion and
they were disguising it like two uh
they've put all the pieces around him so
that
all he's got to do is be accurate and
not have a historically bad offensive
line everything like this has been
pushed to the front to the middle of the
table everything all or nothing has been
fast forwarded on the young quarterbacks
because
everyone's realized that you have to
have value at that position in order to
game the system and for the moment they
have value at that position he's cheap
can you put all the things around him
they've got an offensive line when i
tell you historically bad
dan i think it's impossible impossible
to evaluate what tua is given that he
had less time according to pro football
focus then any quarterback has ever had
more pass rushing more past blocking
failures than we've ever seen since
they've been tracking it i don't i love
that they're entering this season with a
fantasy player that is being described
as a chaos player because everyone
listening to this has an opinion but
nobody listening to this has any earthly
idea what's going to happen with this
quarterback he's dan levitar host of the
dan levitar show with stu gods you and
stu gods okay i mean felt like there was
little friction you had reached out to
me wanting to know if maybe my show
versus your show family feud and then it
felt like you were having a family feud
within your family with you and stu gods
uh yes we're okay i've been married to
somebody for nearly 20 years who's
despicable and i understand what's in my
bed
wow
what what do you mean wow it's a whole
formula
we we were mike and mike odd couple like
what do you mean wow like
wait a minute what do you mean wow you
were at my wedding and stu guts tried to
run off with you he did
he did
what do you mean wow that's people think
that's fake that's not fake that's real
he did take me home
he dropped me off i should say i'm a
hubba he dropped me off okay
you love your wife or stu godz more
what are you talking about who's more
important for your career your wife or
stu guy i love my wife a a million times
more than stu god's i i i barely love
stu gods but i do love him who's more
important for your career
who is more important for my career my
wife is the reason that i'm doing all of
the things i'm presently doing that i
could not do uh with stu gods okay
the the reasons i've made some of the
choices that i've made to protect us all
right so do you want to do this family
feud one day where it's my show versus
your show
i'd like to do it on actual i'd like to
do it on family feud if they ever did a
celebrity family feud or i'd like for
you because you've got game show
connections right everybody listening to
this knows the story of how it is that
you turn down the price is right does
everyone know the story yeah i believe
for those listening right now just
quickly you didn't know that you had
accepted the job to replace
you were going to be drew carey or you
were being asked without knowing the
salary will you take this job it's being
offered to you and your response was but
i need to know the salary correct i was
told that the job was mine
and then they were going to set up a
prices right set in san antonio i was
covering the nba finals they said we
just want to look see how you look on
camera but uh bob barker had signed off
on this
and
then i said well what do i get paid and
they said if you accept the job we'll
tell you how much you get paid
and i said i
i can't do this i can't do this
and what did the job pay
10 million jesus christ yeah exactly
exactly
exactly a total a year yeah yeah yeah
all of a sudden it's like uh and drew
carey is the host of price is right and
he's making 10 million dollars a year my
wife goes
did you know that i go no i didn't i did
not know that
i could never have left these guys
though i could never have left these
people
i made the right decision
no you did not
maybe not but it's okay it's okay i mean
it could be worse i could be there with
stu gotz i mean you can't do both though
it was an either or choice you had the
lip you had the barkley live golf yes it
was an either or yes
don't you other don't you have other
game show experience though you you've
hosted like you could get us in the game
show world somewhere to be able to have
a competition against your show could
you not okay paulie would you get a hold
of the producer we know the producer
celebrity family feud yeah yeah we we
know of him yeah
why don't you reach out and see
i think they had the joe buck family on
there so i mean
i got to believe we're bigger
celebrities than the joe buck family you
are well you are so we could if not
there we'll do it somewhere else we we
should figure out how to do this but i'd
i'd like to ask your group of uh we
we're in the middle of doing our show
and we're just coming out of a segment
okay so i'd like to ask your guys all of
them there and you because we were just
discussing this hypothetically and it's
miami of course
if any of them happened upon a brick of
cocaine
what do they do
a a like on the beach you're walking on
the beach and there is a brick of
cocaine what is the answer uh not having
given it much thought hypothetically
what do you do okay so if this happened
to me again
when i was in miami
so
the first time my answer is different
than the think of cocaine in the car
yeah my answer is different this time
around than the first time that it
happened to me in miami uh let's go
around the horn here um
see i'm going to start with you
so
for no other reason and you look like
you're ready with an answer i would
alert the proper authorities of said
brick of cocaine of course okay marv
i'ma sell that thing
okay
my guys weren't brave enough my guys
were not brave enough to just say it
like that okay fritzy what would you do
if you found a brick of cocaine i would
contact your local police or find out
how to get it to the property
paulie i can't imagine there's gonna be
a reward posted for this because
but if there was that'd be great now i
would i think i turned into authorities
i'd like to think that i would pull a
marvin and put it out there isn't the
movie true romance he finds the the
drugs he tries to sell it
can i change my answer i sell half of it
what fritzy what if you were to sell it
and somehow all of a sudden on the news
there was a contaminated weed or
whatever and people got sick or died
because there was something it's cocaine
not weed and why do you why are you a
buzzkill if it's just sitting there
contaminated someone could get sick from
it and you sold it
let me i want to ask some follow-ups can
i okay
uh next steps please take me when you
say sell it
through the particulars of the next
steps you've immediately found it now
we're combing we're driving home with it
in the car i want all that it's a fair
that's a fair question of of how do you
sell said brick of cocaine
well the first thing you'd have to do
some uh quality control
you gotta make sure and then probably
about a month and a half later and be
broke okay
okay
so you might not sell as much as you
plan but good intentions to sell
yeah uh marv what would you do uh
selling the brick okay
i'd go around see who's who and what's
what
and make sure it doesn't i'm not selling
it
i got you marvin no no no i can't know
what i'm talking about
my guys are street we know we know
what's going on here we're straight out
of connecticut here
you got any other questions here for uh
my posse
uh i do have a question actually for you
here okay chris whittingham is a
lifelong dolphin fan and i want for him
to just read to you in a second the list
of quarterbacks they've had out here
because it's been an irrelevant uh
regional we don't have that much time to
do all of the quarterbacks
well i want to ask you off the top of
your head and i don't think it's a hole
in anyone's uh knowledge to not know the
answer this question can you tell me
when the last time was you paid
attention to the dolphins doing anything
on the field because you thought they
were good like just off the top of your
head when's the last time any of you
guys who work in sports remember the
dolphins being good or carrying i think
i think ryan fitzpatrick made them
interesting for a month that's the last
time that they were
there was a curiosity there of could he
win a game or lose again ryan
fitzpatrick should go into the hall of
fame with tom brady and bill belichick
just because they feasted on him in
every team in that division that is not
uh that ryan fitzpatrick being the
choice for the bills the jets and the
dolphins that represents the best of
what you've remembered no i'm just
saying recent recently uh ryan tannehill
he wasn't entertaining
but he was
serviceable
okay
the jay cutler year they were
interesting
uh okay give him the list winning
pennington
interesting
yeah you know jay feedler and ray lucas
and joey harrington yeah and josh
mccowell
big pen yeah gus farad cleo lemon john
beck
ryan tannehill chad henny aj felix aj
philly
it's just been a morass of awful
see the problem
but the problem is you only like you
guys win six or seven games
like you gotta be worse
that's
like your owner is right
we screw it up and win six or seven
games we gotta be worse than that that's
been your problem you haven't been bad
enough to get good
they were one in 15 one year with cleo
lemon and john beck i do and they could
have been worse that season if not for
greg camarillo and didn't you take an
offensive lineman didn't you take jake
long after a one in 15 season oh my god
dan they have taken you passed on matt
ryan that year i believe
they have taken so many offensive
linemen they have spent so much money on
offensive line they have swallowed nick
saban and bill parcells spending money
on offensive line and they again i will
say this again dan the worst past
blocking in the history of records on
these things last year
i'm glad we could talk
are you i am i always feel better about
my life when i talk to you
don't forget to curse billy gill says to
me in my headset not helpfully uh it was
nice right tangoing with you sir yeah
let's let's do it again and maybe we do
a family feud my family versus your
family i want to do that and the winner
gets a brick of cocaine
and and marv ends up in prison
and marvin's going to do time but he's
going to sell and then we'll make some
money and then he'll be doing some time
thank you dan it's always nice seeing
you buddy that's dan le batard host of
the dan levitard with his former good
friend stu gods we'll take a break we're
back after this